willkommen zur
letzten sitzung, die die letzte
sitzung
der studenten von
et heart zürich und lmu-studenten ist, die
letzte
kombinierte sitzung, die letzte
gemeinsame sitzung,
um diese sitzung, um al, und ich
möchte einen rückblick auf
die vergangenen sitzungen geben
und auch a  Vorschau auf das, was als nächstes
im nächsten Jahr
ansteht, also kennst du zuerst alle dieses Bild von unserer Homepage, ähm kannst es
gerne besuchen, weil es
einige Inhalte
darauf gibt, die für deine Papiere hilfreich sein könnten,
also ist dies der
Zeitplan für dieses Jahr  Sie sehen, die erste
Sitzung
war
im Oktober und dies hier ist die eigentliche
letzte Sitzung. Unsere letzte Sitzung oder letzte
Kommentarsitzung.
Wir haben bisher viele Aspekte der KI diskutiert,
angefangen bei klassischeren Ansätzen
zu
diesem Thema, über
ausgearbeitetere,
zusammenhängendere
Konzepte
bis
hin zu  Die jüngste Diskussion über ethische
Probleme,
und ich werde eine kurze Vorschau und einen
Rückblick geben, ist der erste, den wir mit einer
Lancierung mit seinem sehr berühmten
Artikel über Computermaschinen begonnen haben  nerie und
intelligenz und für diese sitzung hatten
wir einen
blogeintrag auf deutsch,
der die probleme diskutiert,
die
turing
am ende in seinem papier erwähnt. ich empfehle wirklich, es zu
lesen, es könnte nützlich sein und
dir
weitere hinweise und
ideen für dein papier geben  Dann haben wir
einen Wiki-Artikel über das Imitationsspiel,
der sich auch auf Alan Turings Artikel bezieht.
In der nächsten Sitzung haben wir
John Searles
Buch Minds, Brains and Science
und insbesondere das Kapitel über die
Frage, ob Computer denken können, diskutiert,
und auch in dieser Sitzung haben wir es getan  hatte einen
blogeintrag
eine zusammenfassung dieses vortrags den ich dir
auch
empfehlen kann
dort ist auch das chinesische zimmerargument
verlinkt
mit diesem
äh eintrag mit diesem blockeintrag dann sind wir
zu hubert rifus und seiner äh
mehr oder weniger
heideggerschen und späten wittgensteinschen
kritik von ai übergegangen  die frage der
verkörperung
des seins in der welt von ai das ist der
hintergrund des triforce und er ist
auch sehr berühmt dafür, der
erste zu sein  Person, die gegen das Schachprogramm verliert
,
obwohl er ein Buch mit dem Titel geschrieben hat, was
Computer immer noch nicht können und können,
auch sehr
interessant, dieses Buch zu lesen, dann sind wir
zu
diesem Typen hier zu Paul Smolinski
und seinem konnektionistischen Ansatz
übergegangen
wie Sie wissen, gibt es mindestens zwei
Ansätze
für ai, der eine ist der eher regelbefolgende
um-
Ansatz, der andere der eher
konnektionistische oder vielleicht auch
empirische
Ansatz,
dann hatten wir eine Sitzung, die
sich eher angewandten Fragen der ai
durch die
ganz neuen widmete  und eine
wirklich fortschrittliche Firma namens
util. Wir warten auf
ihre
Antwort auf meine Frage
, ob wir die Aufnahme veröffentlichen
können  dass sie
uns erlauben werden, es zu teilen, dann hatten wir
diesen ansatz
der
künstlichen intelligenz von harry collins
und wir diskutierten auch fragen darüber,
wie künstliche intelligenz b  Eingebettet
in größere Zusammenhänge und in der heutigen
Session möchte ich zunächst
das
ganz aktuelle
Oxford Handbook of Ethics of AI vorstellen, das ich
persönlich sehr hilfreich finde,
und hier ist der Inhalt, es ist
wirklich sehr umfassend, es hat so viele
Teile und Themen, dass es  bespricht in der
heutigen sitzung werden wir alle nur
das zweite
äh papier von thomas m powers und
jean gabriel galassia über die ethik
der ethik der ai besprechen. dies ist der
einführungsteil, aber es gibt viele
andere teile, zum beispiel teil zwei
rahmen und modi
, die das
besprechen  frage nach normativität
und anderen normen professionelle normen
in der führung künstlicher
intelligenz
teil drei befasst sich mit konzepten und
themen zum beispiel sexualität
finde ich ganz interessant oder hier ähm
sind empfindungsfähige ais-personen
hier widmet sich ein artikel
ganz der frage der autonomie,
die wir diskutiert haben  In der vorherigen
Sitzung,
die ich mit diesem Video verlinken werde,
sind sie als künstliche Intelligenzen zu
bezeichnen  autonom, obwohl wir in der heutigen
Sitzung diese Frage diskutieren werden
und dann ist Teil vier
Ansätzen
verschiedener Ansätze gewidmet, um
auch
verschiedene
Bereiche
zu interessieren, die von Interesse sein könnten.
Ich kann es wirklich empfehlen, und der letzte
Teil ist eher
Fällen von Anwendungsfragen gewidmet  und anwendungen zum
beispiel hier
migrationsmanagement und
didaktik und so weiter ich finde es wirklich
lesenswert
damit man es nicht kaufen muss ähm man weiß
wie man darauf kommt
und heute stelle ich euch die wichtigsten
fragen also erstmal inwiefern das geht
der begriff autonom und intelligenz
intelligente agenten problematisch in
bezug auf ai die zweite frage,
inwieweit künstliche intelligenz
über- und inwieweit
unterschätzt wird, also müssen wir einen mittelweg finden,
was den umgang mit ai angeht  ai
dritte Frage, welche ethischen
Probleme mit der epistemischen
Wissenserweiterung durch ai verbunden sind und wie
diese adressiert werden können
Die vierte
Frage, die wir meines Erachtens
gemeinsam und nicht in Gruppen diskutieren sollten,
ist, inwieweit eine Ethik der KI
entwickelt werden kann, die sie als Teil
eines sozio-technischen Systems versteht,
das auch wie anno gesagt verbunden ist
frage letzte sitzung
ok und als eine
art
vorschau der vierte teil unseres seminars
seminar ist
nur für lmu-studenten aber
etr-studenten
können wirklich mitmachen sie können bei uns mitmachen also
müssen sie nächstes jahr nicht dabei sein, aber
fühlen sie sich frei  um mitzumachen, wenn du interessiert bist,
also schicke ich den link auch an
alle itah-studenten
und wir werden diese einführungen auch aufzeichnen
und du wirst sie auf
unserem youtube-kanal finden wir werden
mehr
angewandte fragen ai und ästhetik
ai und posthumanismus
und auch wieder diskutieren  Ethische Probleme von ai